Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my Full boys
Gen V Episode 8 finale video.
their were a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
so we'll break it all down
and some teasers for the boys
Season 4
It was meant to directly set up season 4,
especially with a lot of the cameos.
if you're brand new to the channel, I'll be doing
videos for all the boys Season 4 episodes too
and they revealed they renewed Gen V for season 2
they're calling it sophomore year, so to speak,
because they'll continue to be in school basically
with probably a few changes because of the way
they ended the episode.
So of course we'll break it all down.
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning.
We're going through shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments.
starting with the episode title
The Guardians of good-Looking, which is a reference
to Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy and the team name
that Vought came up with for Marie back
when she took credit for stopping Golden Boy,
when really it was Jordan who did it.
And even then Golden Boy kind of killed himself.
At the end of the episode,
she also used the name verbally when she was talking
to Andre, like, Come on, let's all take credit
for taking care of all this.
Even though Vought completely spun things,
the opposite way, saying that they were
the ones that killed everybody on campus and Kate
and Sam were the ones that tried to save everyone.
And they're the real guardians of good-Looking.
just more of a spin machine Homelander
watching the monitors,
the aftermath, kind of laughing, smiling to himself
like see how we swept that under the rug?
Nobody knows about what happened with the wolves.
That was the whole point in their big cover up
is just preventing knowledge of the woods
from getting out
The episode was probably one of the shortest ones of
the season, like it was just a little over 30 minutes,
which is a big surprise.
Usually finales
wind up being some of the longer episodes in series.
during the episode, the Scooby Gang winds up
splitting in two because of Kate's actions.
She goes for Emma Frost, white Queen.
The Hellfire Club goes a little crazy, too, and frees
everyone in the woods using her powers
to sort of rampage on campus,
basically tearing the place apart
with the help of Sam, who's been radicalized
because of what happened at Victoria Neuman's rally
in the Soup Lives Matter movement at the College.
Thank you very much, Rufus.
he's a little bit like peacemaker
from the DC Universe in that
he'll believe pretty much anything
anybody tells him or anything that he sees or reads
just because his mind has been so fractured
and he's been kept in captivity for so long.
So basically, Marie
and the others become the guardians of good talk.
And living up to the fake name Vought was using saving
Ashley everyone else until Homelander can show up
and shut everything down on a dime in 10 seconds
flat like he went for Mace Windu on them.
a lot of the
episode was dedicated to setting up the boys
Season four, which will premiere next year.
that's
what all the cameos were for in the last few episodes.
And the superhero virus storyline,
like Victoria Neuman still has that,
and nobody knows that she has it.
At the end of Episode seven, She'll probably try
to use that to her benefit some way.
On the DL during season four
merrily theory though, and I said this before,
is that I don't think that it will be powerful enough
to actually kill Homelander like she might wind up
trying to use it against Homelander at some point.
In addition
to other superheroes and it'll probably kill them,
but it probably will not be enough for Homelander.
That's how powerful he's meant to be.
although we did just get the invincible Season
two Episode one Premiere video.
A lot of people asking like, who would win in a fight?
Omni-Man or Homelander? And they all agree.
Like the people that make the invincible
Robert Kirkman.
The people that make the boys agreed that Omni-Man
would wreck Homelander like he's way more powerful.
what a coincidence that both of the characters
are now playable in the new Mortal Kombat game.
So you could actually do that matchup
and because they renewed the show just in general
for season two, they kind of teased that
during the ending of the episode, they'll address
what happens to them next.
During season two,
Ashley did temporarily vote marry into the seven?
But it sounds like she took that back because of
the way they spun the news at the end of the episode.
like four, hot second.
She might have cameo during the boys season four had
she's still been on the seven.
but I think now the idea is that they put Kate
and Sam on track for the seven but probably not.
Yeah.
Like they're a little too crazy
to actually bring them on the seven Homelander
probably doesn't want to deal with them so that's why
I don't think we're going to see too many of these
Gen V characters until GMB season two.
basically stuff all the survivors,
the guardians of Goodluck, and down in that
deep dark hole, which is where they put people
that they don't want to deal with
or that they have trouble dealing with,
but they don't want to kill
or they can't kill, like they were giving them
medical attention.
Even Emma had a smoothie.
So like they're actually trying to keep them alive.
But notice there are no doors, there's just a hatch.
So literally, it's kind of like a hole.
during the actual opening scene.
The episode starts right after the ending of Episode
seven, with Kate using her powers
to force the Dean
to reveal her plan about the weapon and kill herself.
So R.I.P., she was kind of a dirt bag.
So I don't think there were a lot of tears
that were shed when she died,
which is the case for a lot of the deaths
during this episode.
And there were many most of the people that died
were all terrible people.
some of the deaths were more spectacular
than others, though.
But the whole idea is that Kate stopped taking her
medication, which had been dampening her powers.
it also sounds like it affects the duration
of how many times
or how frequently she can use her powers
because during the episode
she still winds up having to touch people
to actually control their minds.
but basically all of her recent trauma
she's experienced has caused her to snap mentally
and she decides to destroy the woods Then eventually
they decide to destroy the school itself
With Sam's help, as I said, who barely understands
what's actually going on.
Like he starts to get the ramifications
and he starts hallucinating his brother,
which is basically a representation
of his own consciousness.
like he's talking to himself until later
in the episode when he just has Kate basically
turn that part of his mind off basically having her
put the mute button on his conscience.
For a little while, though, it does seem like he's
a little confused, like, No, no, no.
We have to stop Vought.
We have to stop all this, or they'll capture us
and they'll hurt you.
I need to be the superhero now.
I need to rescue everyone.
Whereas you rescued me previously.
But then he kind of.
One adds on Emma.
Later in the episode,
in the kind of have their version of a breakup.
basically the dichotomy here, if we're making X-Men
Marvel references is the brotherhood of mutants
like Magneto's Brotherhood of mutants
versus Professor X in the traditional X-Men
All the Guardians of God's Skin
would be like Professor Xavier's
X-Men, like the good characters
that don't want to kill a bunch of people
keeping the side of the brotherhood of mutants
who hate all humans,
particularly the people that bought it
also believe superheroes or mutants.
If we're talking about Marvel references
here to be super clear to regular humans,
which is a very homelander kind of belief that she has
that becomes a much bigger thing
at the end of the episode.
And one of the reasons why he has so pissed off
at Marie, like, why are you attacking your own kind?
Because he said that in previous seasons before too.
Like he's even referred to humans in the Harry Potter
kind of way, calling them mud bloods.
the only difference between Homelander's believes
and what Kate is talking about
is that he believes
that superheroes are superior to humans.
But he doesn't want to kill all humans
like Magneto, for instance.
he wants everyone to worship him like a god.
And they can't do that if they're dead.
Andre's father polarity basically tells him that he's
going to take the mantle and wear the suit,
becoming the new polarity
and that he's going to toe the line for Vought
and just do whatever they say
because it brings their family so much money.
And now that his father can't really use his powers,
it looks he kind of understands
that he can't use his powers or he'll die.
He has to become the new breadwinner for the family.
Inside Vought they also clarify what really happened
with his father, like he's having seizures
because of his power, started to create tears
in his brain tissue that they cannot heal.
somebody get a superhero with healing powers
on the line, like somebody with the healing factor.
My only issue with this part of the story
is that healing factors
healing powers are super common in
there are thousands of superheroes out there.
why don't just eventually find a superhero
that can heal that damage?
basically the same thing is happening to Andre.
The more he uses his power,
the more it creates micro terrors in his brain.
He eventually causes himself to pass out later in the
episode too, because he uses powers so many times.
the only saving grace is that he hasn't been
using his powers for nearly as long as his father,
so he has a little bit longer
before things get as bad for him.
but also he has to stop using his powers so much.
if it wasn't clear, the hospital
that they're in right here is Vought Tower.
That's where they treat all their superheroes
so they can keep everything quiet, but also continue
this whole storyline with the micro terrors
in his brain becoming a problem during season two.
They don't really cover that the rest of the episode.
But you do see him pass out like,
that's probably why he passed out.
Then we get our second Ashley cameo during the season.
She appeared earlier during this season
complaining about missing her farm
to table sex party,
which is kind of like another version of Hero Orgasm.
She was going to attend because the college
is starting to lose a lot of money.
they want to do a big PR stunt
to get people excited about the college again.
And they think that putting one of the kids on
the seven will do that.
notice.
They do not care about who's the most qualified,
like who be the best actual superhero.
They just want somebody
with the highest social media stats
that people will like the because the public to spend
way more money on the college.
Like more people want to come to the college
and spend money on tuition
more people will give them money
during their fundraisers.
so when they nominate Andre first,
I think the idea is that
if his father had been there,
he could have advocated for him.
And Andre would have been put on the seven
the couple jokes later in the episode too
like they go to Maverick.
Like who better to fill the hole left
by translucent than translucent son?
But then Ashley puts the kibosh on that
because of all of his kinks.
Like, if he's weird, like his father,
he has all those weird kinks, is going to be
too much trouble earlier during the season,
Maverick said he basically did the same thing
that his father did hiding in bathrooms,
but both men's and women's bathrooms to watch people.
so even though we're not kink shaming here,
he basically had all the same
vices,
did all the same terrible things that his father did,
even though in reality, when Kate wasn't mind
controlling him, he seems like a totally chill dude.
Then she decides to put Marie on the seven.
Like she's like the next person on the list.
Like, Hey, you get to join the seven.
If you kill all the people that are rioting right now.
again, big reminder that Ashley doesn't actually care
who they put on the seven.
It's just a big PR stunt.
and basically by the end of the episode,
it sounds like they've rescinded that offer.
Like she's like, no,
you're actually going in this deep, dark hole in now.
Kate and maybe Sam might wind up
making out of the seven even though I don't that
they're also going to show up until the boys
GMB season two Kate
and Sam free all the woods
and start their rampage across campus.
R.I.P.
Bob and the other guards, the former captains
from the woods start killing everybody inside.
Basically,
They even have a Gangnam Style joke to show you
how long one of the kids has been locked out there.
That was back in 2012, meaning
he's been trapped in the woods for over ten years.
as they're leaving.
Sam start seeing the hallucination of his brother
Golden boy.
It's not meant to be. Kate using her powers on him.
It's actually Sam viewing his own conscience
like it's his conscience talking to him.
So it's basically like him talking to himself,
using his memory of his brother.
it's like the manifestation
of the moral core inside him.
Basically telling him what you're doing
is wrong, like killing all these people is wrong.
So really, he's just talking to himself here.
at least until he has Kate
basically turn that part of his mind off.
Kate makes that last guard
literally eat his own hands.
He'll probably die from blood loss. So R.I.P.
when these are killing
the regular humans left and right.
This one's powers seem like they're acid base.
Kind of like he's melting her face up toed from
the X-Men did have a corrosive acid
that he could spit on people
bonus for Rufus though he winds up surviving.
But now his reaction video
is going to do way more viewers.
And that's like their whole thing,
like they're all meant to be dirtbags doing anything
it takes for more views on their social media
accounts.
Jeff, that weird social manager from the college
manages to kill the super with electric powers?
She seems kind of like a storm parody,
but Kate winds up making him livestream
his own death, like killing himself on live camera
for the rest of the world and see R.I.P..
He was also a dirtbag,
so not really sad to see him go.
And notice
when the security guard on campus who's monitoring
all the security cameras refers to the escape supers
as methods.
That's the code word that Vought used or the cover
story that they use when stuff like that would happen.
Like just blame it all on people's drug addiction.
Ted They're going crazy having mental breaks.
this one is a teleporter.
He seems like a nightcrawler parody.
the couple more funny moments at the drama school
practice with the director character.
There's a lot of him in this part of the episode, too.
one of the students is doing a monologue
from the dawn of the Seven movie.
Obviously, it's a terrible monologue, like,
it sounds awful because the movie itself
is meant to be super schlocky.
I think the actual speech, these reciting is something
that Homelander would have said during the movie.
And apparently the director has a weird thing
about his knuckles, even though he is super freaky
with Ashley, which he jokes about later in the episode
he makes a Josh Hartnett joke, then says it is okay
that he does that because their close personal friends
in barely gets saved by Emma showing up.
Sam and Emma have their version of a breakup
And Sam gets even more radicalized
and he winds up dissing Emma so hard
that she gets so upset
it causes her to shrink it, man, the wasp style
without having to throw up.
So I think this just might be
an evolution of her powers.
And she'll learn more about this during season two.
Being able to grow really big and shrink really small
without having to eat a bunch of stuff
or throw up a bunch of stuff.
Notice when she does this too, she's standing in
the spotlight, kind of like she's giving a performance
just meant to flow with the whole joke here
at the drama school about them giving performances.
the director makes a bunch of jokes
about revealing terrible, naughty
things that he and Ashley
did during a fundraiser event in the bathroom.
It's probably just them doing it in the bathroom.
That's what they did at the bathroom at the premiere
dawn of the Seven, they they implied at the beginning
of season three that the two of them just had
this weird sex thing going on between the two of them.
whatever it was
they did, it was crazy enough for Ashley to freak out
and get them to open the door
before he would say anything about it.
This super uses a sonic scream,
kind of like banshee from the X-Men comics
when laser is super runs through frame,
killing someone.
When that person dies, they use a Wilhelm scream,
which is a trope of a lot of movies
and TV shows, not just like superhero movies
and TV shows and all movies and TV shows.
why don't you start listening for it?
Like once you know what it is,
you start hearing it all over the place,
Then Ashley calls in Homelander as like the cavalry,
so to speak, in their company helicopter.
When Kate mind controls the super strong super
to destroy the helicopter and Andre
rescues it with his powers, lowering it to the ground.
It's kind of like a reverse X-Men Dark
Phenix Easter Egg for Jean Gray's Phenix character.
during that movie, she does basically the same thing,
but she's destroying the helicopter.
Kate. Mind Controls Maverick to attack Marie.
He'd been pretty chill up to this point
to like, actually trying to help them.
Like I said, he seems like a pretty nice dude.
Despite all the kinks that he has.
she uses her blood
bending ability to sense his presence like sense
his blood, so to speak, a central nervous system
in knock him out.
And I think this is the first time
we've actually seen him.
When she knocks him like it
temporarily deactivates his powers to be invisible,
they kind of did the same thing during the boys season
one when Translucent was killed.
Notice Jordan's able to soak the blast from the super
when she changes to his male
form, and Marie uses her power
to slow down their heart temporarily.
And as a much bigger blood bending dagger
move to save the Vought executives.
even though the director says
that he's going to put Marie in his next movie,
remember if she gets put in the deep, dark hole.
So Vought
probably doesn't want her being in that next movie,
You can let me know in the comments what you think
the dawn of the seven two is going to wind up being
The first movie was kind of a parody of both
the Justice League, Snyder cut and Avengers Endgame.
So as both like Marvel and DC parodies,
then she blows up
Kate's hand to prevent her from controlling Jordan.
That's going to leave a mark
that'll carry into season two.
Remember, though,
if she still has that one hand, that's good.
She can still touch people
and use her powers on everyone.
Really, though, it's not about the hand,
it's more about the skin to skin contact.
I think so even if she lost both hands, as long as she
touched her forearm to someone, it would still work.
Then Homelander shows up in his cameo from the season.
We all predicted he would show up eventually
and basically shuts things down on a dime.
Notice that when he lands,
he lands right in front of his own statue.
He's probably gonna be pissed
that they graffitied that.
and he looks pissed that they bothered him at all.
Like, why did you make me show up here? This sucks.
I don't want to be here.
he calls Marie an animal for attacking other supers
and goes with that whole pro super line.
Like, why are you attacking your own kind, getting
pissed off at her, trying to laser and kill her.
but it turns out she's powerful enough.
Her power enables her to survive the blasts just long
enough for them to put her in that deep, dark hole.
they end the episode, like I said, with Cameron doing
what's spin on events, basically saying
that they were the ones that won on the rampage in
Kate and Sam are the ones that tried to stop it,
calling them the real guardians of good talking
basically preventing knowledge of the woods
from getting out in made public
then because this is the comic book property
in Post-Credits scenes are big tropes
of comic book movies and TV shows.
They have a post-credits scene
and it winds up being butcher checking out the woods,
confirming that Malory was talking to him
on the other side of her comms.
he's still probably interested
in that anti superhero virus,
but he doesn't know
or they don't know that Victoria Neuman got her hands.
It that'll continue during the boys season four.
Like I said also the whole concept of Homelander's
trial that Victoria Neuman
teased during episode seven in just in general,
the whole race for the presidency.
Victoria
Newman and Bobby Singer will play a role in that race.
Superheroes getting in the White House, and
it will just continue that storyline from the comics
they haven't really said when the Boys Season four
is going to premiere next year,
my guess is it'll be sometime maybe around like March,
maybe sometime early summer.
It just depends on how long the strikes go.
We probably won't get a boys season
four official trailer until the strike is done.
maybe if that gets wrapped up
in the next couple of weeks before the Thanksgiving
holiday, as I'm posting this video,
we might see some kind of teaser trailer
during December, whatever they wind up releasing,
of course they'll do videos for it.
I've read that a couple of boys season
four teaser trailer videos,
they've released a couple teasers, so I'll post
links for that stuff in the description below.
There's a bunch of big stuff happening this week too.
We also have the Loki finale next week, so be sure to
enable it for my channel so you don't miss that.
an We have Invincible Season
two episodes basically taking over for the boys.
I just did my season 2 episode 1 video
Click here for that and click here
for my full Loki Season two Episode five Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!